closed this is the view many motors see
when arriving at the us-mexico border
last month the two nations agreed to
restrict all non-essential border
crossings an effort to mitigate Kovach
nineteen contagion under the new
emergency coronavirus measures the u.s.
also announced that strict new
immigration policies would be imposed
every week our border agents encountered
thousands of unscreened unvetted and
unauthorized entries from dozens of
countries and we've had this problem for
decades for decades you know the story
but now it's the financial emergencies
and all of the other things that we've
declared we can actually do something
about it we're taking a very strong hold
of that and we have before but this is
now at a level that nobody's ever
approached taking a very strong hold has
meant the closure of immigration courts
and the suspension of hearings for
migrants and asylum seekers most of them
come from countries like El Salvador
Guatemala and Honduras it's a big
concern for all of those who are waiting
for a court hearing date I was meant to
have a hearing on the 30th and because
of coronavirus that has been postponed
all over cases here everyone's it's very
important there are now thousands of
people like Jose Estrada who are in
limbo with no idea how long they'll be
forced to wait in Mexico's migrant
shelters and detention centers under the
new emergency measures US authorities
are conducting fast-track deportations
and enforcing policies that have faced
strong criticism in the past Amnesty
International's Eddie Gaven
says the copic 19 pandemic should not be
used as an excuse to waive any country's
international obligations to human
rights it is relevant to understand a
copy 19 the pandemic is not the result
of migration and I think that this is
extremely important precisely because
governments around the world and
particularly in Latin America and the
Caribbean in the Americas in general the
US Canada are starting to use the
narrative about migration about refugees
stigmatizing this population as if they
were you know
who to blame about this this pandemic
since 2019 some 60,000 non-mexican
migrants many of them asylum seekers
have been denied entry into the United
States under a controversial program
known as remain in Mexico often left
with no choice but to stay at shelters
with notoriously unsanitary conditions
and at a time when health officials are
calling for quarantine and self
isolation as the best defense against
contagion Mexico's migrant centers are
becoming even more crowded manuel
raveloe al jazeera Mexico City